and after a busy day on the domestic
front the prime minister is flying to
brussels tonight ahead of meetings with
allied countries about the attack on
ukraine our david aiken is traveling
with prime minister trudeau and joins us
now with a look at what's ahead on this
trip david
jackson the prime minister is going to
spend the next two days in europe in
brussels meeting with world leaders
tomorrow wednesday he's going to speak
to the european parliament and that's a
rare honor for a canadian prime minister
right now the european parliament is
seized with the issue of food security
russia and ukraine are two of the
world's biggest food producers and food
exporters and if ukraine farmers can't
put their crops in the ground this
spring that has all sorts of
implications for food security not just
in europe but also in african countries
and elsewhere in the world so a lot of
people may look to canada to help canada
can be a bread basket to the world good
thing we got that cp rail work stoppage
sorted out so canadian farmers can put
their crops in the ground so the pm
we'll talk about that then on thursday
the prime minister joins nato leaders
for a nato heads of government summit
one of the issues there is nato unity
nato consensus in the face of russian
aggression some nato countries want to
move a little quicker poland for example
would like to put peacekeeping troops
into ukraine uh lithuania would like to
enforce a no-fly zone canada and other
nato leaders aren't there yet but they
will be talking about that after the
nato summit g7 leaders will meet that
includes the canadian prime minister on
the on the agenda uh the global economy
how to respond to china and after that
the pm gets back in his plane and heads
right back here to ottawa jackson all
right david aiken at ottawa
international airport thanks david